Can you tell us a little bit about
what one of these forecaster's is?
>> Sure, so at a very high level,
forecasting is a pretty simple problem.
What it basically is about.
We do some analysis to calculate demand,
to forecast demand of products in
the absence of any kind of promotional
activity or any other kinds of events,
special events that might cause
spikes or troughs in demand.
And that generates something
called a baseline forecast.
So we have some algorithms
that are responsible for
generating baseline forecasts by doing
an historical analysis of sales data.
We then have a separate
set of algorithms that
calculate what we call
incremental sales.
This is an additional uplift or
it could also be negative uplift
from the base line when certain
special events are in play,
like a promotion, a mother's day
promotion that's going to cause
an uptake in the sale of flowers and
gift cards, right?
Christmas is going to, yeah, or
any other kind of holiday is
going to have and uptake in sales.
So, we tend to think of a forecaster.
The thing that actually calculates
forecasts as being decomposed into
a baseline forecaster and
an incremental forecaster.
And each of those things
can be parameterized.
And then put together to form the actual
forecaster that you want to use to
generate to calculate demand for
products in stores.
So that's a forecaster
kind of in the abstract.
It gives you some idea of what
some of the features in it are and
how they might compose.
>> And can you give us a,
a picture of what this forecaster is
like in terms of its assembly spec.
>> So, if you look at this slide,
you'll see a very simple example.
Probably the simplest example.
I call it the Hello World!
Of forecasters.
And you'll see it just has four lines.
Right.
So, those four lines explain how to
generate four different components
that are used with one another.
In this case, we've got a really
simple one called bForecast, for
baseline Forecast.
One called mults for multipliers.
These are the multipliers that are used
to calculate the incremental uplift
when there are different promotions and
such in place.
We use this two components, bForecast
and mults to generate an incremental
forecast, where they calculate
the actual incremental forecast.
And then, we put the incremental
forecaster and the baseline forecaster
together into a component called batch,
which is a batch forecaster.
And so what that does, and we can go
into in a moment exactly how it does it.
But as you can see, we start with
some kind of elementary components,
the baseline forecaster and
the multipliers.
And then, we compose those with
some reusable features incre for
incremental, and fcst for forecaster.
We compose those together to make
an actual component called batch.
And batch is the component that's
kind of the output of this thing.
That you would then install in your
database to calculate your forecast.
>> So
is this the description of one variant?
>> This is the description
of one variant.
That's correct.